salut les menthe à l'eau je vous fais
une dernière vidéo de mémoire pour vous
faciliter la vie
cette semaine vous ai reparlé de la
table de rappel en vous renvoyant vers
un ancien masterclass que j'avais fait
en début d'année sur la table de rappel
et entre les messages privés sur
facebook sur twitter vous m'avez envoyé
des snav sur instagram j'ai eu des mails
de sa des commentaires de la vidéo me
disant que soit vous aviez du mal à
construire votre propre table de rappel
parce que vous n'aviez pas d'idée soit
vous aviez du mal à prendre
j'ai arrêté j'ai arrêté de compter au
bout de 500 messages pour plutôt faire
cette vidéo plutôt que de répondre à
tout le monde
individuellement donc voici l'ultime
méthode on va utiliser le principe du
système major ou du grand système sap
l'un pleinement c'est un très vieux
système mnémotechnique le principe de
base est très simple vous allez côté les
chiffres par des consoles on remplace le
zéro par un ace - z ce vous
on remplace le 1 par un thé ou un d or
en place le 2 par un n parce que sur le
n ya de pied quand on fait un n le 3 du
coût par un m
leucate par un air le 5 par un l le ciss
alors par tous les sons comme jeu comme
je j'ai eu comme une geôle j'ai eu au et
par ch pour tous les maux en chaussettes
on remplace par un cas comme kiwi par q
u comme quincaillier ou par part
tiens j'ai pas d'idée oui si j'ai une
idée par les gueux comme garou comme
gorille ou comme guillemets 8 par les
sons et consonnes f ou v comme fabien où
vous mentalise et enfin neuf par b ou p
b comme benoît ou paix comme patrick et
pour construire vos images de table de
rappel il suffit d'utiliser ses consoles
en rajoutant des voyelles pour former un
mot exemple concret sur la date
d'aujourd'hui nous sommes le 10
septembre donc le 1 0 slash 09 donc 10
et 1 0 et 1 on sait que c'était ou des
zéros ses leçons s use donc vous donc
l'image ça pourrait être un dessin ça
pourrait être un tesson de bouteille ça
pourrait être une toison ça pourrait
être un tison et puis pour septembre
c'est 09 donc c'est 0 et 9 0c ce ouzou
neuf c'est b ou paie donc on pourrait
faire un sablier ou un sapin ou un
zombie un début
dernier exemple 64 ça pourrait faire une
écharpe
parce que chez eux et peut aller ans le
tente à l'envers je vous laisse le code
là sur le côté je vous donne une image
et vous essayer à linverse de retrouver
quelques chiffres 7 va pour une bougie
bougies bouger bouger les bougies le peu
de neuf le g2 6 donc c'est 96 deuxième
coup encore plus simple une momie une
momie momie à immobile bomy momie il ya
juste 2 m 2 fois le 100 m 2 fois la
console m donc ses 33 cette méthode
c'est sûrement la plus ancienne pour
construire une table de rappel
et c'est sûrement également la plus
efficace aller efficace pour vous aider
à trouver des images jusqu'à 100 et même
plus même au delà
et elle est très efficace également pour
l' inverse pour s'en rappeler pour
travailler sa table de rappel puisqu'il
ya un codage spécifiques
n'hésitez pas à regarder la vidéo
consacrée à l'utilisation de la table
ensuite j'espère que cette méthode vous
aidera à compléter toute la playlist sur
la mémoire dite moi dans les
commentaires s'il ya d'autres
applications de la mémoire que vous
aimeriez que j'aborde ou sur des points
très spécifique des domaines très
spécifiques
j'aime bien vous donner des méthodes sur
un sujet en particulier plutôt qu'un
généraliste n'oubliez pas de mettre un
pouce en l'air de vous abonner à la
chaîne et rendez vous demain à 11 heures
oui parce que hier jeudi 17 heures c'est
11 heures que je voulais dire et bien à
demain ciao
je joue mon spectacle en entier le 23
septembre à la garenne colombes c'est la
date la plus proche de paris si jamais
vous voulez venir sinon il ya toutes les
dates de tournée sur mon site